the Joe Rogan experience the whole world
covered with humans everybody's got it
it's on every and every continent except
Antarctica I think in our cuz the only
place doesn't have cases that's what's
wild about human contact and you think
about how a disease can so quickly
spread from China just all over the
whole world and shut everything down
they said that if China was honest about
it I don't know if this is true but this
is what I was reading in more than one
different story that China could have
stopped 95% of the spread they were just
amazing and not know and they say if
Donald Trump was honest about it they
could have said in mandates for social
distancing and everything a little
earlier I think a lot of people were
real skeptical unfortunately a lot of
people were real skeptical and no one no
one anticipated it happening like this
they were giving him a hard time when he
was saying that they should stop travel
from China people will call him racist
now everybody stopped travel from
everywhere yeah but they want a lot of
people want to call him racist for
[ __ ] goddamn anything if he just said
coffee with no sugar wall see this is
the reason why don't want to [ __ ] with
this [ __ ]
well you know it's it gets clapped the
things get cloudy right because like
what is the thing the thing is he wants
to stop travel from this place because
it diseases in this place and then the
reaction is well that's racist to say
and we should be more sensitive and this
is yeah but people don't understand it
don't move off of emotions the things
that he say is not you gotta understand
it certain people a bill like this
certain people don't make decisions off
of emotions and that's what so many
people get connected and disconnected
with a can or whatever it's like yeah I
[ __ ] rooted for him like it connected
with the emotions and then certain
people like him and people of that like
mind which are mostly business people
they don't [ __ ] with emotions they only
[ __ ] with results it's like oh I feel
sorry did you think well I'd [ __ ] I
don't care about none of that that's not
how I work but what my point oh said if
you got to give the guy a hard time
about not reacting quick enough to
certain things you also got to give him
props for shutting down traffic to
places early but nobody wants to do that
because it's a weird one because the
people that don't want to do that Joe is
the ones that
caught up in the emotion the idea um do
do not get deal with Rio right here
really in that net on the term that I'm
trying to harp on the Trump [ __ ] but
Isaiah Washington you know Isaiah
Washington
hmm yes Grey's Anatomy known him from
years and Brooklyn whatever he's a he's
like like what are you a chump support
he's like a loyal trump supporter you
know I mean oh he's a he's a easy
he's a supports Trump but I've heard him
say say I don't vote for a person I vote
for policies mmm
I vote for policies and I'll give you an
example well this is a weird one down
now because no one had ever experienced
this before no was doing the right thing
having experience with pandemics that
shot the whole world so when he when
anyone's doing anything right everyone's
gonna be criticized 100% but you got to
do like like what people don't like I
listened I don't watch both outlets Fox
and CNN that's confusing isn't it it's
Christmas CNN just where yeah CNN is
like a nagging girlfriend it's like oh
good shut the [ __ ] up you remember that
time you remember that time Fox be like
[ __ ] listen you know I'm saying like
you listen to if you listen to too much
CNN bruh you don't even know what the
[ __ ] is going on with nothing other than
how much you hate this [ __ ]
used to be that way I know cannon used
to be pretty straight journalism yeah a
relationship without so toxic for both
so it's so for both of them it's so I
want to get you back is so like girl I'm
gonna get you back girl it's so popeyes
chicken girl you go 11 herbs and spices
girl it's so in like
when I sorted the point I make it is
like but when I listen what I listen to
both cuz you want to hear both
perspectives if you really care you
listen to both but then when I go to Fox
listen to it I at least here okay this
is what our players are this is what we
want to do mm-hmm
this is what the plans are this is what
the president says he's going to do
this is what the government wants to do
you go on the other side all you hear is
like 1000 people more people die die die
die
that's all years of numbers dumps you
don't have no solution and then the
problem is Jo people get [ __ ] up on
how they want your solution conveyed to
them it's like can you give it to me
slow Joe can you have Vaseline with it
or are you gonna be rough with me and
they can't take a [ __ ] said
[ __ ] can handle rough i'ma get
like this right I'm gonna get my
Democrat right and I love being a
Democrat until tax season you know how
close I was to putting to make America
great again
yeah well the point I'm making and I'm
proud and exempt for a lot of people I'm
a small business you know I'm a vet I'm
a veteran I served the United States Air
Force I did my time they're gonna say
how good of a Airmen I was but I
committed four years of my life to this
country you know I'm saying and if
there's it is not about let's take away
the [ __ ] about but the way he made me
feel and then he said that he's such a
so let's let's take away that in my
situation as a lot of people that are
I'm a small business and my vet and the
things that he'd do for those type of
people is easy for me to say I could
justify it if all I'm thinking about is
money and paper I could justify yeah
[ __ ] because of that but it's people
the disconnection right now with this
election I feel is that everybody has
even they're using everybody sticks us
on emotions mmm it's all on how I feel
oh I like this guy like that guy like
this guy whatever you know this is like
this [ __ ] was gonna come into
this election and just beat the [ __ ] out
of anybody
the economy was doing well you're not
I'm saying the pond and hope my whole
thing was with anybody getting upset Joe
what are you gonna fight this
[ __ ] with this time you don't
have no more fighting styles yeah well
being pissed
[Applause]